elle fait face à des déficits et une
vague de protestations tous azimuts les
familles les blouses blanches même les
vapes hauteur sans compter la droite qui
appelle à la mobilisation contre ces
annonces et l'église également qu'ils se
mobilisent pour la politique familiale
bonsoir marisol touraine
ministre donc des affaires sociales de
la santé et également des droits des
femmes à ce n'est pas une sinécure en ce
moment on peut le voir comme le dit
françois hollande il n'y a pas de
réforme qui soit indolore pourtant vous
affirmer qu'aucune famille ne verra
baisser le montant des prestations
qu'elle reçoit alors vous vous
expliquerez sur ce point tout à l'heure
avec karim perret de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire pour
preuve par trois comme chaque semaine
avec dailymotion et bien sûr perrine
tarneaud de public sénat ce sera là pour
la troisième partie de l'émission
d'abord marisol touraine la révolte ce
mardi des professions libérales
notamment médicale celle qui vous
concerne directement le combat ne fait
que commencer
ont-elles affirmé dans la rue en fermant
a également les cabinets les officines
quels gestes pouvez vous faire pour
apaiser les médecins les pharmaciens je
dis bien à quel geste sympa pas quels
propos
aujourd'hui il ya eu une manifestation
forte une mobilisation forte de la part
de ce que l'on appelle les professions
réglementées il y à des professionnels
de santé mais il ya aussi les notaires
les huissiers de justice par exemple des
professions qui sont concernés par le
projet de loi sur la croissance qui
avait été élaboré par arnaud montebourg
et qui est maintenant porté par le
nouveau ministre de l'économie emmanuel
macron pris acte du succès de leur
mobilisation
je pars en tout cas des professionnels
de santé et plus spécifiquement des
pharmaciens je l'avais annoncé il ya
déjà quelques jours leur mouvement a été
fort et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'avais pris soin de demander aux
agences régionales de santé de mettre en
place un dispositif de garde pour que
les français qui avaient besoin de
trouver des médicaments puissent trouver
des médicaments malgré le mouvement des
pharmaciens on leur dit pour les apaiser
emmanuel macron lui même a aujourd'hui
eu des propos apaisants sur la manière
dont l ouverture du capital des
pharmacies se ferait ou ne se ferait pas
il peut se faire ou il n'est pas pas se
résumer décline se prépare alors
emmanuel macron a indiqué qu'il ne
fallait pas d'inquiétude que la manière
dont étaient organisés les pharmacies ne
serait pas substantiellement transformer
ou changé et maintenant il pourra y
avoir des investisseurs non
professionnels donc qui sont pas du
secteur de la santé dans les pharmacies
travail le travail va se poursuivre je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas avoir
entendu emmanuel macron que ce soit ça
ses objectifs et sa volonté je vais vous
donner l'exemple d'une transformation
qui me paraît très souhaitable que des
salariés qui travaillent dans des
pharmacies puisse entrer au capital de
leur femme assise ce pourrait être une
bonne chose de façon à associer
l'ensemble de ceux qui travaillent au
sein de cette formation
les intérêts financiers
aussi c'est une transformation les fonds
de pension c'est une mauvaise chose
votre faute évidemment garantir
l'indépendance des pharmacies ne serait
pas possible que par exemple l'industrie
pharmaceutique soit au capital des
pharmacies ou que des médecins soit
qu'ils sont prescripteurs soit au
capital des pharmacies je crois que nous
avons la chance j'en suis même certaines
d'avoir en france un système de
pharmacies qui est un système rassurant
pour nos concitoyens les pharmacies sont
proches des français elle apporte une
garantie sur la sécurité des médicaments
et elle apporte des conseils est ce que
le système des pharmacies peu évolué et
est ce que la profession peut te se
moderniser la réponse est évidemment oui
et j'ai moi-même lancer des actions en
ce sens j'ai fait en sorte que les
pharmacies et les pharmaciens plus
exactement soit très actif dans le
développement des médicaments génériques
j'ai fait des pharmaciens les
partenaires pour la vente des
antibiotiques à l'unité c'est un
bouleversement dans notre vie nous dit
qu'il pourra y avoir des évolutions dans
le capital de ses pharmacies qui sont
des sociétés d'exercice libéral par
exemple que connaît salariés de la fin
des pharmacies accéder au capital de ces
pharmacies ça me paraît une bonne
initiative mais je veux dire moi qui
suis ministre en charge de la santé que
la priorité qui est la mienne c'est
d'apporter toutes les garanties à nos
concitoyens qu'ils pourront continuer à
trouver des pharmacies à proximité de
chez eux ce qui suppose qu'il y ait des
pharmacies qui s'installent dans des
territoires y compris des territoires
ruraux les campagnes par également il
n'y a pas trop de pharmacies en france
certains rapports le dise il ya
peut-être trop de pharmacie dans
certains endroits mais ne faisons
attention à ne pas introduire une
logique libérale
de laisser faire qui aboutirait ce que
les pharmacies ou les pharmaciens
s'installerait systématiquement dans les
centres villes pour l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé pour les
pharmacies comme pour les autres je suis
attentive à ce que les français puissent
se trouver à côté de chez eux ce dont
ils ont besoin des médecins des
infirmières des kinés et d'autres
évolutions possibles et envisageables je
vais pas vous allez nous le confirmer ce
que vous allez faire sortir certains
médicaments des pharmacies pour les
rendre disponibles dans les grandes
surfaces pour qu'il soit ou qui serait
t'il d'ailleurs moins cher on dit que
c'est l'objectif je n'y suis pas
favorable
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire et je le
répète et je souhaite que tout cela soit
clarifié définitivement très vite pour
éviter d'entretenir de faux débat je n'y
suis pas favorable pourquoi parce que
les médicaments ne sont pas des produits
de consommation les médicaments ne sont
pas des médicaments qui sont classés
comme tel mais qui ne soit pas remboursé
par la sécurité sociale et irait
questions majeures des dentifrices mais
j'étais sceptique mais il y à des
produits qui aujourd'hui sont classés
comme médicament et qui au fond n'ont
pas de raison de l'être j'ai moi même
pas osé j'ai moi même proposé d'engager
un mouvement tout à fait indépendamment
de la loi qui est engagée et qui est
préparé pour déclasser ou déclassifiés
certains produits certains dentifrices
des produits par exemple pour la peau
l'éosine pour ne mentionner
la colère des sérums physiologique non
j'ai travaillé avec les représentants
des pharmaciens et ils sont prêts eux
mêmes à réfléchir on prépare à réfléchir
à proposer des produits dont eux-mêmes
considère qu' ils n'ont pas besoin du
conseil du pharmacien pour être vendus
en revanche je considère pour ce qui me
concerne que les médicaments doivent
être encadrés strictement et je vais
même vous dire une chose dans notre pays
le problème c'est qu'on consomme encore
trop de médicaments et ça n'est pas en
mettant des médicaments en vente libre
dans les pharmacies qu'on va régler ce
problème moi mon mouvement jeune mon
objectif ça n'est pas que les français
trouvent n'importe où ou à quelques de
nouveaux endroits des médicaments c'est
qu'ils soient plus attentifs et mieux
maîtriser dans leur consommation il y va
de leur santé et il y va d'ailleurs lors
de la qualité de notre système de santé
les généraliser justement la vente de
médicaments à l'unité là pour faire des
économies j'ai lancé
présentation expérimentation va durer un
an au bout d'un an nous tirons les
leçons de cette expérimentation pour
voir s'il ya des des aménagements à
apporter mais je suis dans l'intention
de généraliser la vente des
antibiotiques à lumino parce que on
consomme trop médicaments coûtent cher
en consomme trop d'antibiotiques dans
notre pays alors vous voulez faire
baisser le prix de certains médicaments
donc en les sortant des pharmacies 1
vous le confirmer quand même avec
l'accord des formations vous l'avais dit
il ya quelques mois nous avons permis la
vente des tests de grossesse dans les
grandes surfaces et cela est plutôt
quelque chose de positif le disons que
la spécificité de la vente en pharmacie
ne s'imposait pas mais moi je suis très
attentive à faire la différence entre ce
qui relève du conseil du professionnel
de santé ce qui relève de l'accès de
alors chaque site concernant les
médicaments il ya d'autres enjeux
financiers alors qu'ils sont bien plus
considérables c'est est-ce que la
sécurité sociale peut aujourd'hui par
exemple payer à quelques deux cent mille
patients qui sont atteints d'hépatite c
dans notre pays un nouveau cachet
miracle de laboratoire américain vous
avez annoncé un ensemble de mesures oui
à encadrer un peu les labos avec des
taxes mais ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
carrément envisager une mesure radicale
c'est à dire s'emparer des brevets il y
a une chance formidable pour nous
aujourd'hui et je pense à tous ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui malades de l'hépatite c
qui ne savaient pas comment se soigner
de façon satisfaisante il y a encore peu
et qui aujourd'hui ont la possibilité de
se soigner bien avec ce nouveau
médicament cinquante six mille euros
vécurent là c'est quand
même plus oui j'ai engagé une
mobilisation européenne pour que nous
fassions en sorte ensemble de peser sur
le laboratoire américain et d'échanger
des informations qui nous permettent
d'avoir un prix plus satisfaisant et
puis j'ai engagé au niveau national
parce que je veux aussi pouvoir agir au
niveau national j'ai engagé une
procédure de négociation ferme avec ce
laboratoire et un encadrement du prix
qui sera votée dans le cadre de la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale je
veux dire il s'agit pas par exemple vous
enrichissez médicaments par d'autres
laboratoires c'est une avancée
considérable que celle que je propose et
qui est d'ailleurs reconnue comme telle
par l'ensemble de ce qui fera baisser
les prix pourquoi on dit que j'allais
grossiord parce que moi j'ai une
exigence et une volonté c'est que
chacune chacun dans notre pays puisse
continuer d'accéder aux soins de qualité
à l'innovation dans de très bonnes
conditions et doctorat il s'agit de
faire à ne pas à n'importe quel prix
mais il n'y aura pas de rationnement des
soins moi je n'accepterai pas que l'on
dise parce que le médicament est cher il
y à des malades qui ne pourront pas y
accéder et donc je mets en place comme
depuis deux ans une politique qui repose
sur deux principes
l'efficacité et la justice l'efficacité
pour pouvoir obtenir un prix qui soit un
prix abordable mais la justice et la
justice en matière sociale c'est de
garantir l'accès à notre système de
soins c'est une force 1 atout
considérable pour notre pays et cela je
le défendrai oui c'est un bosseur mais
alors donc ça c'est les pays dans
lesquels on envisage de rationner les
soins en raison du coût des médicaments
on ne le fait pas et on ne le fera pas
ce que vous dites pour l'hépatite c mais
on sait qu'il ya d'autres molécules
prometteuses pour le contre le cancer
contre le cholestérol est ce que selon
vous le losc est le prix que demande si
laboratoire est justifiée par le coût
des recherches ou bien est-ce que c'est
simplement de la pure spéculation
l'innovation doit être rémunéré il est
normal qu'un médicament nouveau et
apportent un progrès soient payés plus
cher qu'un médicaments plus anciens il
n'y a évidemment aucun doute là dessus
en revanche il faut arriver à déterminer
ce qu'est le prix juste on ne peut pas
payer n'importe quel prix et je crois
d'ailleurs que les laboratoires
l'entendent la concurrence permettra de
faire baisser des prix et nous devons
faire en sorte de mettre en place des
mécanismes qui permettent d'encadrer les
prix vous savez c'est de cette façon là
qu on garantira à chacune à chacun de
pouvoir accéder aux soins et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut être très
attentif aux économies que nous portons
dans le système de la sécurité sociale
parce que les économies ça n'est pas
l'ennemie de la qualité des soins au
contraire c'est la garantie que notre
système de protection sociale pourra
continuer de se développer et répondre
aux besoins des français on va parler
dans un instant de lait des économies
dans la politique familiale mais encore
une question sur sur les maladies des
économies en matière de santé et
notamment le développement des
médicaments génériques
sinon bull à toi je chasse aux examens
qui doublonnent et c'est un gros sur
tous et toutes ses économies ce sont des
économies de structure ça veut dire que
l'on fait évoluer avancer notre système
de santé pour qu'il réponde mieux à la
réalité des besoins de santé je veux
dire que les économies ne doivent pas
être présentés de manière négative
punitive ils doivent être présentés
c'est une exigence c'est une exigence de
faire des économies mais moi je veux que
ces économies répondent à la mise en
place de réformes de structures qui
permettent en même temps de londres où
défilent aujourd'hui les économies ne
sont pas punitive mais elles ne peuvent
pas être indolore a dit le chef de
l'état vous allez pouvoir vous expliquer
maintenant puisque vous faites face un
vent de révolte je le disais après vous
annonce d'économies dans la branche
famille de la sécurité sociale avant
donc de répondre aux questions de karine
perret de la fp voyons avec louis
sybille quelles sont les mesures dont
qui aujourd'hui mobilise je le disais
tout à l'heure la droite des
associations familiales et même
monseigneur vingt-trois
attendu au tournant les ministres du
budget et de la santé ne font pas fier
figure le trou de la sécurité sociale
est certes moins important qu'en 2013 11
milliards 700 millions d'euros de
déficit mais c'est beaucoup plus que
prévu et se réduit toujours pas aussi
vite que certains pourraient elles
souhaiter ou que nous avions nous-mêmes
prévu mais le déficit est de 800
millions d'euros inférieur à ce qu'il
avait été l'année dernière donc on aura
une diminution de ses déficits et pour
le diminuer encore les ministres ont
tranché 3 milliards 200 millions d'euros
d'économies sont prévues pour 2015 si la
branche maladie est la plus mise au
régime c'est la branche famille qui fait
le plus parler d'elle premier coup de
rabot le congé parental de 3 aujourd'hui
et devrait être réduit mais surtout il
doit être mieux réparti entre père et
mère une volonté de parité qui est une
entourloupe pour les associations de
familles car ce sont les femmes qui
prennent ces congés très majoritairement
aujourd'hui elles sont 97 % et ce sont
les familles les plus modestes qui vont
en pâtir
ce qu'on est en déficit aujourd'hui de
places de crèche d'approximativement
trois cent cinquante mille places avec
les congés parentaux actuelle ce déficit
va encore s'accentuer et donc le système
d le travail au noir va forcément encore
plus se développer ce qui est tout à
fait dommageable autres économies la
prime pour l'enfant de 923 euros elle
sera divisé par trois pour le deuxième
enfant d'autres mesures sont prises
comme la diminution des aides pour faire
garder son enfant pour les ménages les
plus aisés au total ce sont 700 millions
d'euros d'économies de prévu mais à quel
prix
pour l'opposition c'est la politique
familiale qui détruites la france a la
chance d'avoir ce dynamisme
démographique ce qui n'est pas le cas
par exemple de l'allemagne eh bien on va
porter un coup fatal à cette politique
familiale qui a obtenu ces résultats qui
a fait ses preuves et qui donne une
chance des atouts une avance dans la
compétition internationale à notre pays
le trou de la sécu est régulièrement
montrée du doigt dans le cadre du pacte
de responsabilité la sécurité sociale
est pourtant appelé à faire 21 milliards
d'euros d'économies d'ici 2017 un
objectif qui semble bien impossible
alors voilà donc un sujet hautement
sensible
on va pas rentrer dans une querelle de
chiffres la sécurité sociale ne sera pas
mise à contribution pour 21 milliards il
ya aussi l'assurance chômage d'état de
politique ne relève pas de la sécurité
sociale les prestations sociales
politiques sociales au sens là
est ce que vous pensez comme votre
collègue du gouvernement ce matin
ségolène royal qu'il faut se réjouir de
la contestation de toutes ces mesures
annoncées sur les politiques familiales
la politique familiale en france est une
chance formidable c'est un atout pour
notre pays et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je l'ait soutenu portée que la
gauche fait de la famille et des
politiques familiales à leur jeu tout à
fait important moi je ne laisserai pas
dire je vous le dis sincèrement je ne
laisserai pas dire que la gauche n'aime
pas des familles parce que depuis deux
ans nous avons investi un milliard
d'euros supplémentaire
sinon d'euros d'économies et willy des
sources vont continuer d'augmenter à un
rythme plus maîtrisé il y à des
économies il y à des économies parce que
si nous ne faisons on l'a vu dans le
sujet s'il n'ya ne sont pas ces
économies viendra le moment où ne
pourront plus assumer notre modèle
social et moi je le répète ma priorité
mon comment dire mon exigence
quotidienne ma volonté quotidienne c'est
de faire en sorte que notre modèle
social protecteur soutiennent l'ensemble
des familles et l'ensemble des français
et pour cela nous devons regarder les
dépenses que nous faisons simplement ses
dépenses nous devons les faire à partir
de certains principes toutes les
familles doivent pouvoir compter sur la
solidarité nationale et c'est le cas oui
mais ça ce sont les principes de la wii
mais ce souhait principe oui on remettra
en quoi vous les hommes et 100 balles et
partiellement par exemple avec la le
report de l'âge de 14 ans à 16 ans de la
majoration d'allocations apporter ça
n'est pas un principe oui c'est un
report de deux ans l'unaf a calculé que
les 1500 euros à spa nous le faisons
pourquoi est ce que nous faisons parce
que nous adaptons le versement des
prestations à l'âge des enfants à quel
moment est ce que les enfants se mettent
à coûter beaucoup plus cher c'est à 16
ans à peu près à l'entrée au lycée où un
enfant se met à coûter aussi cher qu'un
adulte pratiquement et bien donc nous
ajustons nos prestations sociales pour
tenir de cette vérité c'est quand même
une perte de pouvoir d'achat on est il y
a une économie où ils y ont il ya mal de
perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les airois
temps de plan mais les familles qui
aujourd'hui ont tous une allocation
parce qu'elles ont un enfant par exemple
de 15 ans continueront d'avoir la même
alors qu'ils fabriquaient nécessaire de
13 ans va de va devoir va voir les
nouvelles règles et impliquait donc voir
l'aja ne sera pas diminué non mais il
sera quand même amputé non il ne sera
pas diminué il aura la majoration de la
deûle à la location
tant que l'on fera la voix et laura mais
un peu plus tard mais j'insiste sur ce
point les prestations familiales des
familles ne vont pas être touchées elles
ne vont pas diminuer elles ne vont pas
être mises à contribution pour les
enfants à naître ou pour les enfants qui
grandissent il va y avoir des
ajustements mais ce n'est pas la même
chose de dire vous recevez une
allocation on va vous l'a diminuée que
de dire eh bien vous auriez demain vous
allez avoir un enfant et vous allez
avoir des règles de jeu nouvelle cela
veut dire concrètement que nous ne
changeons pas les règles du jeu au
milieu de la partie et nous disons aux
français ce que vous avez aujourd'hui
vous l'aurez demain ça c'est un portait
alors un couple qui va avoir un enfant
permettant au 25 décembre aura les
règles en vigueur aujourd'hui une prime
de naissance de près de 900 euros et un
couple qui aurait un enfant mettront le
5 janvier aux trois fois moins mais
alors là avec lui avec sme et vous
pouvez l'envié oui au contraire qu est
ce que les familles qui naissent les
familles qui se forment aujourd'hui ont
le même cadre de vie qu'il y a vingt ans
parce que avec ce type de raisonnement
on ne changerait jamais rien et la
réalité c'est que la société bouge c'est
que notre environnement bouge que les
sociétés les familles se transforme
notre société les femmes autour de lui
tout aussi besoins nouveaux par exemple
elles ont davantage besoin de places de
crèches et de places d'accueil parce que
les femmes travaillent parce qu'il y a
de plus en plus de familles
monoparentales et nous savons que les
familles monoparentales sont plus que
les autres exposés à la pauvreté c'est
pour cela que nous garantissons le
maintien des allocations qu'ils ont
honte en direction des familles reims
évoqué l'idée que ça pourrait
faire baisser la natalité en france
est-ce que vous avez mesuré l'impact de
ces mesures sur la démographie je ne
peux pas croire que l'on fasse ses
enfants en calculant le montant des
allocations que l'on va percevoir
pendant 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans d'abord
parce que l'environnement peut changer
vous savez faire des enfants fonder une
famille c'est un geste de confiance
c'est la confiance dans la vie réelle
confiance justement avec jc va devenir
un luxe coûte et vraiment je ne peux pas
croire que ce soit parce que il y aura
des ajustements qui resteront limitées
pour chaque phase minute par exemple en
2013 vous avez aussi fait passer à
l'abaissement du plafond pour les
quotient familial je veux dire il ya
pour des familles et des paragons
famille quad et ça crée une incertitude
tous côtés depuis qu'elle incertitudes
depuis deux ans depuis deux ans nous
avons lancé un programme massif de
création de places de crèche et
d'accueil des enfants 25 des places de
crèches des assistantes maternelles en
plus et des enfants accueillis à l'école
avant trois ans nous avons augmenté de
25% l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
donc aujourd'hui les familles les
familles dans notre pays peuvent compter
sur une allocation de rentrée scolaire
est augmentée de 25% les familles
modestes qui sont des familles
nombreuses peuvent compter sur une
revalorisation de l'allocation de
complément familial
je peux vous ajoutez les les actes que
nous avons pesé moi ce que je veux dire
c'est que je ne doute pas qu'il y ait
des efforts qu'ils soient demandés mais
ces efforts ils sont demandés d'une
manière qui est juste nous avons besoin
d'une politique efficace pour rétablir
le système de protection sociale et la
droite aujourd'hui fait son unité elle
est désunie sur beaucoup de sujets elle
son unité en brandissant le thème de la
famille mais qu'at-elle fait à saluer à
cinq jours d'une manifestation de la
manif pour tous c'est comme ça qu'elles
se nomment est ce que vous craignez pas
que toutes ces mesures fasse appel d'air
franchement le budget de la sécurité
sociale s'élabore sans tenir compte du
calendrier des manifestations de ce type
là et nous nous sommes engagés dans une
politique d'efficacité de justice mais
aussi de responsabilité financière
vis-à-vis de l'avenir la droite nous a
transmis une
politique familiale en déficit en
déficit important et donc nous nous
assumons nos responsabilités mais nous
le faisons avec la volonté que les
familles modestes soient préservés soit
protégée soit accompagnée et je dis
franchement ne brandissons pas des
étendards de de clivage d'opposition
systématique
nous nous travaillons au quotidien pour
faire en sorte que la vie des familles
au quotidien s'améliore et qu'on
l'appelle jusqu'en février le
gouvernement avait retiré son projet de
loi famille juste après une année ça me
propose alors à dire qu'il n'y a pas de
fait pas les choses en fonction du
calendrier
dévoilé la loi a été votée fin elle a
été elle a été elle est là elle a été
représentée au parlement et elle a été
votée faute est d'ailleurs une loi de
protection des enfants re disons les
choses clairement vous savez je constate
que la droite agite des épouvantails dès
que nous parlons famille on nous
explique que tout de suite nous
voudrions brader les valeurs familiales
dans notre pays nous voudrions légaliser
la gestation pour autrui la gpa alors
que nous y sommes fortement opposés que
j'y suis personnellement totalement
opposés parce que c'est la
marchandisation du corps des femmes donc
on voit des amalgames ce faire et je
trouve que cela ne sert pas la politique
cela ne sert pas les familles dans notre
pays il est comme pour le mariage ce
n'est pas la manif porto ce qui vous
fera reculer sur la politique familiale
dont bruno le maire dit il faut se
mobiliser mais la droite essaye de de
ressouder ses rangs à partir de cette
thématique là parce qu'au fond elle ne
sait pas comment
avancer aujourd'hui
pour l'avenir mais par exemple
monseigneur vingt-trois a dénoncé lors
d'une homélie assez ferme le
démembrement progressif de la politique
familiale et 10 et un coup sévère aux
mesures c'est un coup sévère pour
l'avenir du pays le démembrement d'une
politique qui aujourd'hui représente
combien michel grossiord plus de 50
milliards d'euros consacrés à la
politique familiale 36 milliards d'euros
qui sont consacrés aux prestations
familiales et nous parlons de 700
millions d'économies 700 millions
d'économies qui vont être répartis selon
des principes qui sont des principes de
justice et d'accompagnement des modes de
vie les femmes travaillent les femmes
ont besoin d'être soutenu avec des
places en crèche des places d'accueil
les familles ont besoin aussi de service
et pas uniquement de prestations c'est
pour cela que nous investissons parler
aussi de la de la droite mais de les
critiques émanent aussi de votre propre
camp est ce que ça sera pas compliqué à
l'assemblée est ce que vous allez
pouvoir vous épargner le recours à
l'article 49 3 pour le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
j'abhorre de tous les débats
parlementaires et j'en ai
mené un certain nombre maintenant mais
j'aborde tous les débats parlementaires
avec confiance fermeté et esprit de
dialogue et de discussion un texte
parlementaire un texte présenté au
parlement il fait l'objet de débats il
fait l'objet d'amendements et dès lors
que les objectifs recherchés sont
respectés des aménagements peuvent
évidemment être trouvé je mets
évidemment tous les textes de lois font
l'objet d'amendements de discussion et
d'aménagement et je souhaite qu'il en
aille de la même façon pour le texte sur
la sécurité sociale qui ne comporte pas
seulement d'ailleurs des mesures sur la
famille mais aussi des mesures sur la
santé sur le recours à l'article 49-3 je
suis jamais dans cette perspective là
parce que nous avons besoin d'échanger
d'avancer et de faire voter un texte qui
est un texte encore une fois de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'avenir et
qui marque l'engagement extrêmement
ferme de ce gouvernement
engagement personnel pour que notre
modèle social puisse être à la fois
adapté et confort est revenir sur une
mesure plus précise le congé parental
pour le deuxième enfant va-t-il
continuer a duré trois ans sera-t-il
pris moitié-moitié par l'homme la femme
pouvez vous nous préciser les choses ça
fait partie des mesures qui feront sans
doute l'objet d'une discussion même si
elles doivent pouvoir se traiter manière
non législative quelle est la situation
il y a aujourd'hui la possibilité pour
les femmes à compter du 2ème enfant de
prendre un congé parental assez long de
trois ans pour le premier enfant le
congé parental est plus court la loi du
4 août sur l'égalité réelle entre les
femmes et les hommes a d'ores et déjà
introduit le principe d'un partage sans
préciser le oui mais ça n'est pas
inscrit dans la loi donc à inscrire le
principe d'un partage et bien est-ce que
se partagent peut-être encore plus
équitable aller par exemple vers une
répartition
18 mois pour la femme 18 mois pour
l'homme ou un autre critère de
répartition qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
nous allons mettre dans la discussion
l'idée d'un partage équitable
les hommes et gagnent plus que les
femmes en moyenne dans notre pays
malheureusement tant qu'ils ne prendront
pas ce congé parental donc ses croyances
économie donc à ce moment-là ça veut
dire que au fond nous accepterions que
les femmes se contente de quelque chose
que les hommes ne trouverait pas à leur
niveau
de valeur suffisante pour eux c'est
quand même une manière de concevoir
l'engagement des femmes le travail des
femmes de manière que je trouve
préoccupant et gmail égalitaire jumelles
aux jeunes mes bras vous savez bien que
les chiffres justement et 97% salué les
congés bien sûr son prix parler c'est ça
qu'il faut faire et l'écart de revenu
est elle pour un homme puisque les
hommes gagnent esprit les flux passion
que ce ministre des droits des femmes ma
préoccupation n'est pas simplement celle
de l'égalité ma préoccupation est celle
de la présence des femmes sur le marché
du travail et donc je ne crois pas qu'en
restant en dehors du marché du travail
les femmes se prépare à une carrière
professionnelle le contenu va être mais
cette mesure cette mesure suppose qu'il
y est un engagement fort et ferme en
faveur des places de crèche c'est le cas
et suppose aussi que l'on facilite la
formation professionnelle des femmes qui
sont restés en dehors d'une activité
professionnelle pendant un certain temps
alors ça vous en fait un des combats
personnels puissent et c'est comme ça
que vous présentez votre action
ministérielle marisol touraine et veut
justement il ya un autre sujet c'est
votre plan anti tabac vous voulez que
les bébés qui naissent aujourd'hui soit
la première génération de non fumeurs
dont vous avez présenté un sound
l'objectif de mead solution également de
mesures dont une qui fait polémique
c'est votre manière dit on de
stigmatiser leva potage ça a créé
beaucoup de remous faisait pouvoir
répondre à perrine tarneaud dans un
instant mais d'abord le reportage de
saviano scheer
je pourrais vous dire une dernière fois
que je faisais mais on sera peut-être
plus une campagne choc à l'image du
nouveau plan national de réduction du
tabagisme
le ministère de la santé a dévoilé la
semaine dernière une série de mesures
dont l'instauration d'un paquet de
cigarettes neutre l'interdiction de la
cigarette électronique dans certains
lieux publics ou encore une aide
renforcée au sevrage tabagique
nous disons enfin parce que la ministre
a annoncé un vrai plan il n'y a pas eu
d'engagement politique aussi ferme
pratiquement
depuis la loi evin mais les deux
millions d'usagers de la cigarette
électronique eux sont en colère c'est un
vapo tant que brice lepoutre a réussi à
s'affranchir du tabac un geste qu'il ne
pourra bientôt plus faire dans son
bureau le gouvernement veut l'interdire
sur les lieux de travail pour ne pas
banaliser le geste et et inciter au
tabagisme brice lepoutre devra donc
vapoter dehors les vapes auteurs vont
être repartez avec les fumeurs on va les
ressources m au tabagisme passif on va
les remettre à la tentation de vouloir
se grillent une cigarette de tabac c'est
du vécu on a nos adhérents qui ont leurs
entreprises qui ont interdit dans le
règlement intérieur leva potage au
travail en a environ 75% des gens qui
replonge dans le tabac une mesure que
regrette aussi ce tabacologue pour qui
le gouvernement se prive d'un outil
essentiel ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que pour lutter contre le tabac on
dispose de trois grands outils le
premier c'est la variation de
l'augmentation des prix plus les prix
augmentent fort comme ici vous voyez ma
plus les ventes de tabac chute le
deuxièmement on dispose d'action comme
l'interdiction dans les lieux publics a
le troisième effet passé celui de la
cigarette électronique et vous voyez que
depuis qu'elles sont en devenue efficace
et que les gens s'en servent de plus en
plus et bien les ventes de tabac chute
seulement pour le gouvernement le vha
potage encouragerait les jeunes non
fumeurs à passer à la cigarette un effet
passerelle auxquelles ne croient pas ce
professionnel sans les trois pays dans
lesquels la cigarette électronique est
libre à l'achat ou en grande bretagne
aux états unis et en france et bien
effectivement de plus en plus de jeunes
qui va potes mais dans le même temps de
moins en moins de jeunes qui fument et
la cigarette électronique est en train
de ringardiser la cigarette
conventionnelle et ça c'est quelque
chose de formidable autre grand regret
l'absence d'une augmentation drastique
du prix du paquet de cigarettes qui a
pourtant déjà fait ses preuves
voilà perrine tarneaud est avec nous
euh non fumeuse
aux questions sur le sujet mais j'ai pas
dit ça
rennes reste que le voc potage n'est pas
finalement le meilleur moyen de lutter
contre la consommation de tabac je
voudrais qu'on parle du tabac et du plan
tabac parce que c'est anti tabac parce
que c'est ça l'essentiel mais je réponds
à votre question parce que beaucoup de
questions en votant oui mais j'ai dit
les choses de manière extrêmement claire
il faut distinguer entre ceux qui fument
déjà et pour eux la cigarette
électronique
c'est très bien si ça leur permet
d'arrêter ou de passer de la cigarette
classique du tabac qui est très nocif à
quelque chose qui est moins nocif pour
eux formidable je le soutiens jeu
l'encouragent mais en revanche pour ceux
qui ne sont pas encore rentrés dans le
tabac ma préoccupation c'est que le vha
potage le soir à la porte d'entrée il y
à une étude du haut conseil pour la
santé publique qui dit attention
attention parce que au fond on est en
train de créer autour de la cigarette
électronique de nouvelles habitudes de
nouveaux gestes qui peuvent encourager
les commandes et même sa part passe de
lys garrett de la cigarette électronique
il en a pas brusquement justement parmi
les jeunes est ce qu'il ya des études
sur l'étude du haut conseil pour la
santé publique que je vous évoque mais
l'essentiel pour moi n'est pas là
l'essentiel c'est de mener une bataille
résolu et ferme contre le tabac parce
que le tabac ce sont 73 mille personnes
qui meurent chaque année le tabac c'est
une personne qui meurt toutes les sept
minutes
et pour prendre une image un peu
frappante le tabac c'est comme si chaque
jour un avion s'écrasait avec 200
personnes à bord évidemment on ne le
supporterait pas il y a dix ans on n'a
pas supporté cela pour les accidents de
la route qui pourtant maintenant font
vingt fois moins de morts que le tabac
il est en plus que temps et c'est ce que
dirait associations de mobiliser
l'ensemble des normes et un accord
difficile on dit ça y est le message
leva peau de cole alors juste sécher
occupons nous des fumeurs préoccupons
nous de ceux qui tombent malades qui ont
des cancers chez les lions sécher contre
lesquels est contré enfin maladies
contre lesquelles il faut évidemment se
battre pied à pied alors deux questions
les chiffres que vous avez cités sont
effectivement insupportable et
dramatique dans ce cas là pourquoi on
n'augmente pas tout simplement
drastiquement considérablement le prix
des paquets de cigarettes
c'est la mesure d'un service et bien
c'est fait c'est une option sont ré
était une option le prix du tabac le
prix du paquet de cigarettes est en
france déjà un des plus élevés ce que
disent toutes les études absolument
toutes les études c'est qu'il n'y a pas
une mesure qui marche quant à eux qu'ils
prononcent jeudi avec d'autres ce que
disent toutes les études dans tous les
pays du monde c'est que ce qu'il faut
c'est avoir un plan cohérent qui
permettent de jouer sur plusieurs
leviers et c'est pour ça que la
présidente de la ligue contre le cancer
que le président de l'alliance contre le
tabac que l'ensemble des associations
qui sont impliqués ont salué ce plan
parce que pour la première fois depuis
des années on a un ensemble de mesures
le paquet neutre c'est un changement un
bouleversement qui va s'installer dans
notre pays mais je le dis le pack est
notre seul n'est pas la meilleure
miracle il faut au fond montré une
détermination collective à ne plus
accepter les ravages du tabac comme il y
a dix ans il y a eu une détermination
collective à dire les accidents de la
route ça suffit des jeunes de 20 ans qui
meurent de la voiture ça suffit tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé d'une certaine
nocivité de la cigarette électronique
quel danger représente
exactement la cigarette électronique la
cigarette est dit je vois que vous avez
une préoccupation karassine a reçu des
messages
on a les réponses je n'en doute pas mais
je n'en doute pas mais il ne faut pas
comment dire confondre l'essentiel et
l'accessoire
l'essentiel du plan c'est de se battre
contre le tabac et le tabagisme
c'est de faire reculer le tabagisme
vous avez
pour ce que tu ne fumes déjà oui ce qui
est déjà énorme marisol touraine mais
jeu et cela n'est pas remis en cause
est-ce que deux exemples autour de nous
des personnes qui ont arrêté la
cigarette
huit mois dites-moi concrètement en quoi
est-ce que les mesures qui ont été
annoncées vont empêcher les vapes
hauteur de vapoter je voudrais quand
même avoir une réponse parce que
regarder revient dans les réseaux si on
écoute par exemple le reportage combien
vous avez diffusé envoyé ce monsieur
qu'ils aient ben voilà maintenant je
suis obligée d'aller fume la cigarette
électronique sur le trottoir avec les
autres fumeurs et à l'habileté ça va
m'inciter à reprendre un mégaphone au
tabagisme passif
cl ils peuvent apporter
lorsqu'il n'y avait pas de papoter
c'est-à-dire il ya un an ou un an et
demi il pouvait tenir dans son bureau
sans fumer pendant 2h 3h 4 or je suis
étonné de voir que tout d'un coup il
faudrait ne mettre aucune limite il ne
s'agit pas d'interdire
il s'agit d'encadrer vous savez moi je
ne considère pas du tout que il faille
multiplier les contraintes interdire
pour interdire il s'agit simplement de
fixer des règles il ya beaucoup de
domaines dans lesquels il y a des règles
et je ne vois pas pourquoi pour la
cigarette électronique
il faudrait considérer que c'est
l'absence complète de règles qui est la
seule solution je ne parle pas
d'interdiction je parle d'encadrement à
des questions sur les amateurs est ce
que vous allez recevoir
s'ils veulent que j'ai fait plein de
demandes
vous avez refusé de les recevoir je n'ai
pas rencontré les pluralistes alors que
je rencontre les personnes qui d'accord
travaille dans le milieu de la bande
l'utah verte la loterie des auteurs
comme il ya lojie des séries sûrement
mais vous savez maintenant de messages
qu'on a reçu oui mais nous avons fait
les études et le dire y compris aux
vapoteurs nous avons fait des études
avant de lancer notre réflexion et
l'élaboration de nos propositions et
plus de 55% des vapoteurs souhaite qu'
il y ait des règles qui soient fixés
donc on peut toujours
expliqué que personne ne supporte aucun
encadrement la réalité est différente
une autre question qui se pose autour de
votre plan anti tabac il interdit aux
parents de fumer dans des lieux privés
leur voiture en présence de leurs
enfants est-ce que ça c'est pas une
atteinte finalement aux libertés de
chacun d'entre nous une atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales c'est une banque
à dreux mans de la liberté individuelle
de fumée au regard d'un intérêt plus
important qui est celui de la santé des
enfants la france n'est pas le premier
pays à s'engager dans cette voie
d'autres pays l'ont fait et vous me
permettrez de penser que c'est une
mesure de bon sens parce que fumer alors
qu'on a un enfant dans un espace clos
alors même que l'on sait les ravages du
tabagisme passif ça n'est pas
responsable et moi je n'ai aucun doute
sur le fait que cette règle sera
respectée très simplement parce que les
parents ne souhaitent pas empoisonné
leurs enfants il y aura des rappels à
l'ordre des gendarmes dans un premier
temps et après peut-être une
verbalisation
il peut y avoir comme des âmes en comme
il ya aujourd'hui des amendes qui
peuvent être donné à quelqu'un qui
refuseraient d'éteindre sa cigarette
dans un restaurant ou dans un lieu
public on va parler un peu égalité
femmes hommes ont parlé tout à l'heure
de noël mais là on change d'univers on
change d'univers
les sénatoriales les ont vus la parité
peut progresser ici au sénat on est
passé de 23 % de femmes à 25% est-ce que
selon vous du coup il faudrait des
règles encore un peu plus contraignantes
pour imposer la parité
il faut que les partis jouent le jeu
parce que si les parties ne s'engagent
pas à présenter des femmes et et bien il
n'y a pas de résultats satisfaisants
la progression 23 25 % de femmes élue
sénatrice c'est évidemment insuffisant
et nous avons beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir encore je crois qu'il faut
être déterminé déterminé à ce que des
femmes soit candidate pour parce que
pour que des femmes soient ténue donc l
épargne santé femmes candidates et
candidats que là où elles peuvent régner
pas uniquement là où c'est impossible
gérard larcher désigné aujourd'hui par
le groupe ump du sénat pour être le
candidat de droite pour la présidence du
sénat est-ce que selon vous on en a 10
politique c'est un front un peu anti
sarkozy qui s'est manifesté aujourd'hui
au sénat on disait que chacun soit
répandu un cem et effectivement j'ai lu
entendu
l'ancien président de la république
s'était engagé pour jean pierre raffarin
dont je ne sais pas ce que cela veut
dire sur son influence ou
l'appétence des sénateurs les cno
l'ancien président a écouté en tout cas
il ne semble pas que la
l'influencent de l'ancien président ne
semble pas être marquée à l'intérieur du
sénat je veux qu'on dise quand même un
mot sur ebola on a des nouvelles plutôt
rassurantes de l'infirmière française de
msf qui a été rapatriée en france elle
va mieux mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous annoncer la l'efficacité des
traitements qu'ils ont été administrés
l'infirmière qui a été hospitalisé à
l'hôpital bégin va mieux je lui présente
bien sûr tous mes souhaits de guérison
rapide elle a reçu plusieurs traitements
expérimentaux et je ne suis pas en
mesure de vous dire quel est le
traitement qui peut avoir eu un effet ce
sera aux médecins de se prononcer et on
ne peut pas se prononcer sur un cas mais
en tout cas cette infirmière a reçu
plusieurs traitements expérimentaux elle
a été prise en charge dans de très
bonnes conditions et je souhaite que les
mener les nouvelles rassurantes que nous
avons aujourd'hui soit confirmée elle
reste hospitalisée et donc je suis
toujours prudente d'accord ultime
question puisque on a beaucoup parlé de
votre plan d'économies pour la sécurité
sociale vous avez dit tout à l'heure 700
millions d'euros c'est bien cela marisol
touraine malheur je pensais un autre
chiffre on vous et pourquoi parce que
pour la politique familiale pour la
politique familiale est alors que l'on a
découvert récemment en grâce à la cour
des comptes que la fraude patronale aux
cotisations sociales qui sont
déterminantes évidemment pour le
financement de tous par ces 20 milliards
d'euros c'est quand même incroyable à un
chantier qui rapporterait des mineurs et
la sécu serait bénéficiaire c'est un
chantier très important d'où vient cette
fraude cette fraude elle vient notamment
de l'embauché ou de l'emploi de
travailleurs qui viennent d'autres pays
des fameux ça va venir y chercher et qui
sont employés c'est une double peine
pour les salariés français parce qu'ils
sont embauchés moins cher et donc il ya
une concurrence un peu comment dire
qui n'ait pas assumé les alizés français
citation c'est du travail au noir mais
donc ils sont moins payés et ya pas de
cotisation pour la sécurité sociale
c'est pour cela que nous avons lancé une
offensive au niveau européen pour faire
en sorte de mieux encadrer ce travail
mais je crois qu'il faut être très
attentif à cette situation là et net ne
faire preuve d'aucune
bienveillance d'aucune tolérance à
l'égard de ces conditions d'embauché
merci d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
marie seul toit de mercy perry n les
bons soirs à 20h